malheureusement depuis quelques semaines
tournesol et hors ligne nos développeurs
ont soulevé des craintes vis-à-vis des
risques de sécurité informatique pour
protéger les données personnelles sur
tournesol ainsi que pour éviter des
injections de fausses données dans le
compte de nos contributeurs
nous avons alors préféré rendre
tournesol momentanément indisponible le
temps de réécrire tout le code et de
l'audit et avec soin nous espérons
revenir en ligne d'ici quelques semaines
avec les fonctionnalités minimales
malheureusement on concevoir un site web
fonctionnel et utilisables simultanément
par des centaines de milliers
d'utilisateurs hashtag c'est compliqué
d'autant que ça correspond pas vraiment
mon expertise
si l'on veut faire de tournesol un
succès si on veut permettre à des
milliers voire des millions de
contributeurs de partager leur jugement
sur quelles vidéos youtube devrait
davantage être recommandée et si on va
signer à tout vidéo un score de
fiabilité peu de temps après la sortie
de la vidéo
il va falloir malheureusement fournir
beaucoup de travail l'éthique de
l'information
ça demande beaucoup de temps d'énergie
et de moyens nous avons besoin de
beaucoup d aide pour espérer y arriver
et donc si vous pensez que ça en vaut la
peine
si vous pensez que des informations sur
leurs réseaux sociaux est devenu un
enjeu de société majeur
et si vous êtes prêts à donner de votre
temps de votre énergie et de votre
expertise pour soutenir la quête de
solution fiable sécurisée et
transparente
alors sachez que vous pouvez aider et
peut être même être payés à nous aider
comme vous l'aurez peut être deviné
aujourd'hui ce qui nous fait le plus
défaut c'est le développement d'une
plateforme web de tourner au sol et en
particulier de son back end le backend
c'est le code qui est exécuté par les
serveurs de tournesol pour gérer la base
de données répondre aux requêtes et
calculer les scores des vidéos sur
tournesol ce code et écris en django
libre et open source à ses standards
dans le langage python
vous pouvez ainsi jeter un oeil au bac
est de tournesol qui comme tout surtout
au sol et open source et en licence
libre
plusieurs bénévoles ils travaillent
actuellement notamment les excellents et
d'un designer albéric parmi d'autres
ainsi que lui faut qu'on le trésorier de
l'association
mais on a clairement besoin de davantage
d aide pour intégrer plus de fonctions
et surtout pour auditer avec soin le
code qui est écrit si ça vous intéresse
beaucoup et si vous en avez les
compétences
j'ai une excellente nouvelle pour vous
une offre d'emploi vient d'être publiée
par le pfl il s'agit d'un contrat en cdd
d'un an renouvelable pour devenir
ingénieur de recherche ou dans le
laboratoire de calcul distribué du
professeur rachid guerraoui dont la
mission est précisément de contribuer au
back end de tournesol en collaboration
avec des chercheurs de pf elle une
candidate ou un candidat idéal aurait
plusieurs années d'expérience en
développement de back-end et de l'open
source
connaître et jango sur le bout des
doigts et aura une bonne compréhension
des risques de sécurité et des enjeux de
mise à l'échelle des sites web
sachez que la personne retenue
travaillerait principalement avec moi
mais aussi avec d'autres chercheurs et
développeurs à la fois brillant et
formidablement sympathique
cette personne devra de préférence venir
à lausanne pour profiter des belles
plages des magnifiques montagnes
il dépose au café fortement recommandée
le salaire sera celui de la grille de
salaires pour les ingénieurs de
recherche de le pfl qui dépend de vos
diplômes et de votre séniorité et entre
nous c'est un salaire suisse donc c'est
vraiment pas mal donc si ça vous tente
n'hésitez pas à candidats étaient
directement sur la page de l'offre
d'emploi et sinon je vous serai
également très reconnaissant
si vous pouviez transférer l'offre
d'emploi à d'autres personnes
potentiellement intéressées par le
projet tourne au sol et par la recherche
de pointe sur l'éthique et la sécurité
des algorithmes et bon je crois l'avoir
déjà dit mais je vais insister à nouveau
dessus
lausanne c'est vraiment super génial
surtout pour ceux parmi vous qui adore
la montagne où le lac
bien sûr au delà du bac n dans les mois
à venir on va aussi avoir besoin de
beaucoup de contributions pour le
frontend l'application mobile et les
extensions chrome firefox à la fois au
niveau du code mais aussi en termes de
design et d'expérience utilisateur
là encore la meilleure façon de
contribuer c'est de commencer par
d'abord vous familiariser avec le projet
en visitant notre github
en rejoignant notre discorde et en
lisant notre white paper j'ai mis tous
les liens en descriptions
tournesol soulève aussi énormément de
défis de recherche qu'il est urgent de
résoudre pour rendre la plateforme plus
efficace sécurisé et agréable à utiliser
ces défis de recherche sont nombreux sur
le plan théorique ils sont mentionnés
notamment dans le white paper technique
de tournesol est là pour le coup c'est
vraiment mon domaine d expertise
donc si vous êtes chercheur et si cela
vous intéresse de résoudre les défis
théorique
alors n'hésitez pas à me contacter
directement alors beaucoup de ces défis
tourne autour du machine learning en
particulier du machine learning robuste
je vous renvoie d'ailleurs à nos
articles récemment soumis pour plus
d'informations à ce sujet notez qu'il ya
aussi des questions qui ne sont pas
directement relié au machine learning
mais plus à des questions d'informatique
théorique notamment au sujet de la
validation des comptes ou des problèmes
d'optimisation ce polar à l'heure
toutefois il vaut mieux ne pas à
détester la théorie des probabilités
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de trucs un peu
bayésiens derrière tous ces sujets de
recherche
ceci étant dit il ya également d'énormes
défis à relever pour passer du plan
théorique à la pratique qui inclut
d'ailleurs des questions plus ou moins
directement relié à tourner au sol comme
mesurer les performances empirique des
modèles d'apprentissage conçu pour être
au buste d'un côté du spectre à des
déploiements de solutions d'activ
earning ou d'apprentissage décentralisée
pour tourner au sol à l'autre bout du
spectre et là encore si vous êtes
chercheuse ou chercheurs et si cela vous
intéresse de déployer des solutions
j'ai encore une fois une excellente
nouvelle pour vous de pf elle vient
d'ouvrir notre offres de jobs
cette fois pour une opposition de
post-doctorat encore une fois dans le
laboratoire de calcul distribué du
professeur rachid bouraoui une candidate
ou un candidat idéal maîtriserait
parfaitement paille torche et houle
tencer flou mais connaîtrait aussi le
développement web pour déployer des
solutions pour tournesol typiquement
pour ceux qui voient ce que ça veut dire
l'une des idées serait de faire quelques
étapes de descente de gradient
directement dans le navigateur de
l'utilisateur pour décentraliser les
calculs et éviter la surcharge du
serveur
ce qui permettrait de servir
efficacement potentiellement des
millions de contributeurs de tournesol
on a aussi plein d'autres idées de
recherche l'intervention soit est
utilisé des algorithmes d'apprentissage
encore plus sophistiquées encore une
fois la personne retenue pour ce post
doc travaillerait principalement avec
moi mais aussi avec d'autres chercheurs
brillant et merveilleusement sympathique
à le pfl et encore une fois cette
personne devra subir l'horrible vue sur
les montagnes et sur le lac et
participer au moins de temps en temps à
des pauses café
là encore si vous connaissez des gens
dans votre entourage qui pourrait être
lassé par ce poste s'il vous plaît
pensez à leur transférer l'ofs
au delà des contributions
au code et à la recherche vous pouvez
contribuer indirectement via des dons à
l'association tournesol
ces dons seront ensuite utilisées soit
pour embaucher des employés pour tourner
au sol sauf pour investir dans la
promotion de tournesol actuellement
tournesol n'a pas d'employés nous devons
étudier différentes opportunités
actuelles pour mieux déterminer quelles
sortes de profils sont plus urgents à
recruter interne quoi qu'il en soit nous
souhaiterions recruté à la fois des
profils techniques pour contribuer aux
codes mais aussi des profils plus
managériaux notamment pour prendre soin
des contributeurs relier les
informations importantes et écrire des
demandes de financement entre autres
nous souhaitons aussi utiliser vos dons
peau sponsoriser des créateurs de
contenus de qualité notamment sur
youtube avec en contrepartie une
promotion de tournesol à l'intérieur des
contenus ainsi produit et un appel à
contribuer à tourner au sol en espérant
que ce genre de publicité sera plus
robuste mans bénéfique qu'une énième
publicité pour north bay pn autres ceci
dit ces partenaires attendront
certainement septembre le temps que le
site web de tournesol reviennent en
ligne et soit aussi fonctionnel et
facile à utiliser que possible de façon
plus générale tant que tournesol et hors
ligne
la promotion de tournesol a toutes les
raisons d'être mise en veille cependant
dès que tournesol sera à nouveau en
ligne vous pourrez grandement contribuéà
tournesol en en parlant autour de vous à
vos proches à vos collègues et à des
personnes influentes pour qu'il devienne
cool est normal de juger des vidéos sur
tournesol et de vouloir rendre les
recommandations de vidéos plus robuste
mans bénéfique à ce moment là il y aura
bien entendu une façon beaucoup plus
direct encore de contribuer à tourner au
sol il suffira de fournir des jugements
sur la plateforme tournesol en comparant
différentes vidéos en espérant que d'ici
là on aura aussi implémenter un
mécanisme de garantie qui permettra à
plus de comptes de devenir certifié
mais même si vous n'êtes pas certifié
juger des vidéos nous sera très utile
le simple fait que nous puissions
disposer d'une base de données publique
toujours plus grande
pourra suffire à motiver plus de
chercheurs à s'intéresser à tournesol et
à promouvoir tournesol à leur tour
tournesol est un immense et fabuleux
chantier j'espère que je peux compter
sur votre aide pour que nous puissions
accomplir ensemble